yeah i'm i'm not keep i'm not keeping
anything
but what's one that you would like
warner brothers i'm not keeping anything
i promise
uh the car but one that i might like
might be some of the iconic ones like
a guard an angel blade or
um you know maybe some of the uh
the non the non-lethal weapons that we
uh we used but
uh i will say that the the big one
is one that i can share that i i am
taking home with me and that was
that was sanctioned by warner brothers i
i'm getting the car
what have you not told anybody about
that i may have mentioned it but
i i that's big news that's big news
that's incredible are you gonna
are you gonna drive it are you gonna
keep it in your garage and just keep it
there you know for all time's sake
my my plan as of now is when the show
when we wrap up the show here and
here in a few weeks they're gonna hand
me the keys and i'm gonna put that
sucker on a car carrier
ship her home to texas uh and i've gotta
i got a couple of folks that
uh um that i'm talking to uh is that
your contract did you say i want that
mic
it was what season did you do it uh i've
been talking about that for
two years now and it finally they
finally added that to my contract this
last season
is there a double there is and they i
think they offered it to jared i don't
know if he's going to take it because
it's you know it's kind of beat up and
it's
i'll take it
ah dude that's so cool man that was
coming home with me
and it's i'm gonna i'm gonna clean her
up but not change
not change anything like but i'm gonna i
might just you know
i'm gonna need to add an air
conditioning unit because we live in
texas
uh i'm probably gonna probably get some
new speakers and a a
radio system in there that actually
works i'm blown away i'm blown away by
this
but everything else i'm just i'm going
to leave the creek in the doors the
splits and the seats
you know it's all going to be the same
can i ask for one thing can i ask for
one thing if it's still around
what i think you'll you'll laugh at this
and you'll be like you know what i bet
they still have them
i want you to sign it with a silver
sharpie for me and i'm going to keep
them right there on my table
your tap shoes from
your tap shoes for the singing and the
rain [ __ ] i want the black tap shoes
because you had to wear tap shoes
i want them is that possible i had to
yeah i could see where those are
yeah that would be huge there's a lot of
wardrobe stuff that i i you know they'll
have a huge wardrobe sale
uh at some point i don't know when but
there's a lot of stuff that was that was
built for me you know
there was there was like specific uh i
there we did a western episode where we
get sent back to like the 1800s
we have to find samuel colt because he's
got a he's got a gun that bullets that
we've got to get
so we get sent back in time and
you know of course my character goes
full uh
you know dodge city uh wyatt herb style
and they give me they hand make me just
duster and these you know
full on like periods so those will
probably be for sale
yeah well but they you know it's it's
all
molded to me so i i might have to
that one might disappear may it
disappear i still want those tap shoes